what's up
guys bang bang it's lunch money time
we're not sitting in the kitchen no
we're not we now have a nice little
studio more on that later
we're not filming on a potato either
don't forget pelina you might not have
seen her in a while
she's still here as a co-host i just
banged her against my
shoulder blade there that was awesome uh
don't forget the lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto on a crypto exchange
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
or you can use my favorite product the
interest bearing account where you
deposit crypto and earn up to eight
point six percent
apy on that interest bearing account
go to block five dot com slash pomp
today block
i just want to say thank you for
everyone who has expressed concern
nobody about where we have been we are
here
we were setting up this lovely studio
but more on that later first topic
yep bitcoin focused firm galaxy digital
holdings has agreed to buy
bit go for 1.2 billion dollars in cash
and stock
the first billion dollar deal in the
cryptocurrency industry
are we gonna see more unicorns unicorn
deals
now that we have this nice [ __ ] does
that mean that i'm gonna have to be
serious
yes okay let everyone doesn't know this
story about bitco bitco
actually spun out of another company
they tried to build something else it
didn't work
they were persistent they were dedicated
and they kept
at it they're now selling for 1.2
billion to galaxy mike novogratz and the
team over there
they want to move from an asset
management firm somebody who just
invests capital to actually want to
build things now they want to own things
they want to own businesses they want to
own products they want to build that
stuff
they want to build a full stack crypto
behemoth it's pretty cool to see them
doing that and bitco
is one of the leaders in the industry so
it makes a ton of sense but it is
interesting that
these types of deals if they are more
and more in the crypto industry
it's good for crypto of course listen
it is the future of finance if you're
not paying attention it's the future
finance
all right coin metrics a cryptocurrency
and blockchain data provider stop it
i always find easy ways to coin metrics
a cryptocurrency and blockchain data
see i can make her laugh no matter where
we are at home
in this stupid studio which is not so
stupid because it looks
pretty cool i tried to put the logo up
here couldn't figure it out so then i
tried to put netflix and she yelled at
me so
that's why nothing's on the screen so
coinmetrics is cryptocurrency and
blockchain data provider to
institutional clients
every time you do that it's loud raised
15 million dollars through investors led
by goldman sachs
the firm plans to use the proceeds to
grow in europe and
asia to create new products and expand
current offerings
coinmetrics started by nick carter and a
couple other folks uh probably one of
the best
uh data sources in all of crypto very
very interesting
you see the legacy yeah financial
organizations participating leading this
round not traditional venture
capitalists
do we think jp morgan's going to start
doing that jp morgan definitely is going
to use the data they have to use data
to make all the decisions that they're
making but i don't know if they're going
to necessarily start doing venture
investing in crypto companies
visa has partnered with fintech startup
tala
is it tala this is basically turned into
a crypto show drive
crypto adoption for under banked
customers in emerging markets
the companies will begin by providing
access to usd coin the stablecoin backed
by the us dollar
and they will collaborate with circle uh
visa is making big moves visa
understands that there is the potential
that there could be very big problems
with
uh a payment system that is open that is
decentralized and that could potentially
remove them from their monopolistic
position in the market
and instead rather than trying to fight
it rather than trying to say this is
stupid and ignore it
they are choosing to embrace it to
partner to build
things in the space i think it's very
very smart this is the classic
innovators dilemma do you ruin your
existing business or do you go and
actually use the new technology i think
visa is making the right decision here
and history will be very kind to them do
do we think visa by investing in all
these startups is actually looking at
potential acquisition targets
yeah they're definitely going to acquire
companies they're going to invest in
companies they're going to build stuff
all that stuff all right the new york
giants team has locked down the nfl's
first corporate cryptocurrency
partnership with grayscale
investments what does that mean when you
say new york giants
you must say the greatest football team
in the world
the new york giants remember the new
york giants all you guys are are out
here
acting like the patriots and tom brady
are your gods
oh and two against eli manning and the
giants in the super bowl
i don't want to hear it next i don't
even care about football i just wanted
to talk about the nf what does a
corporate cryptocurrency partnership
mean i think what they're doing is
basically they've made
grayscale the official digital currency
asset manager of
the greatest football team in the nfl
the new york giants
and what that will do is allow grace
keller to go in they're going to educate
the players the team the personnel
they're gonna do all sorts of great
stuff in terms of
providing infrastructure and it's
basically an advertising and marketing
deal so
long grayscale uh long the new york
giants we're probably gonna win the
super bowl this year
i say that every year sometimes it
happens sometimes it doesn't but we're
the greatest football team in the nfl
see now people are going to unsubscribe
because of your comments i support
everyone except the giants
um okay so so that's for the people who
are gonna she also gives out
participation trophies and doesn't
believe in winning
listen to this story a farmer in belgium
has caused the stir
after he accidentally redrew the
country's border with france
um the belgian farmer apparently annoyed
by this stone that was in his tractor's
path
had moved it inside french territory
i mean do you think that the belgian
farmer cares about the
border the border or do you think he
cares about getting his tractor where
he's
obviously he cared about his tractor but
that's hilarious i kind of kind of
respect this person
we don't know if it's a man or a woman
but we kind of respect them it's a man
he could face criminal charges which is
garbage he failed to comply
but he wait who's he oh the uh
some like minister said if he shows good
will he won't have a problem we'll
settle this issue
amicably i think he should keep the
border there
okay it's that's lunch money time i
don't have a specific question lined up
but i do have because we haven't done
lunch money in a while and no one was
able to help
people asked where is lunch money do you
want to say what we've been doing for
the last few days
so you can't see it right now but uh
we've been building a studio
and the studio is not just for lunch
money it's for the podcast it's for all
kinds of different things
uh that's where we are right now we are
working on the aesthetics we are working
on not putting netflix on the television
because my wife doesn't like when i try
to watch netflix on the television in
the middle of the day
instead she wants to have the logo
hopefully by tomorrow we will have the
logo there
just my face and also we are working on
a bunch of other things that we'll talk
about in the future
but we and i now have these nice
microphones that i can annoy her with
and also we have really nice cameras
hopefully we look fantastic
in like a gazillion hd or whatever 48.
did you film this on a potato how you
like me now
mike jones you know that song
i don't know mike jones all right i have
a meeting to go to but
saya sayonara is that a word it's
goodbye yes goodbye
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan what
you're a bigger fan of block five than
you are of me block lies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polena
they've got three products they can give
you a us dollar loan
you can earn up to 8.6 interest on an
interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends